donald trump ist diese woche endgültig
aus dem pariser klimaabkommen
ausgestiegen
denkt man so spontan und dann fällt
einem ein wir sind ja gar nicht besser
unser sogenanntes klimapaket entpuppt
sich immer mehr als luftnummer beispiel
landwirtschaft verantwortlich für knapp
ein zehntel der deutschen treibhausgase
was nicht zuletzt am methan liegt das
aus rindern kommt sagen wir mal
sehr romantischer film so
und wenn ich spüle rumliegen lassen
wissen sie entsteht noch mehr methan wir
brauchen also biogasanlagen und
gasdichte kühle lagerung das kostet geld
was bauern brauchen sind also klare
ansagen wer das bezahlen soll
was sie in deutschland kriegen sind
kalender sprüche und die landwirtschaft
ist nicht irgendein wirtschaftsbereich
das wissen wir
weil landwirtschaft prägt landschaft und
wenn landwirtschaft nicht mehr da ist
wird aus landschaft einfach nur noch
gegend wenn ideen nicht mehr da sind
wird aus ministerin noch weinkönigin
aber das ist eine andere geschichte so
im klimapaket steht die gruppe und ich
zitiere wünscht sich langfristig weniger
vieh haltung weniger rinder
das ist aber eine reine
absichtserklärung das kann man da einmal
so ein schreiben natürlich klar man muss
aber schon sagen wie das gehen soll und
man wünscht sich dass mehr heimische
pflanzen verfüttert werden weil die kühe
dann weniger methan produzieren
leider ist aber dass soja futter aus
südamerika effektiver und günstiger also
warum sollen die bauern das machen bei
denen absurd niedrigen milchpreisen
leben die doch jetzt schon eher vom bio
strom und rainer gille verdienen jetzt
mehr geld oder
sozusagen mit der scheiße ja gülle heißt
auf dem land die neue währung oliver
welke empfiehlt jetzt den shit coin
investieren bringt mehr als bitcoin je
schreibt bitcoins der letzte chance
glauben sie ich bin experte
das ganze
doch zurück zum thema das ganze system
milch ist durch und durch krank was da
den armen kühen angetan wird das geht
wirklich auf keine kurt und den bauern
ja auch den bauern ja auch für den
export von milch vor allem nach china
produzieren wir gigantische überschüsse
damit die weiße bluse in willich bleibt
für industrie und handel
während landwirte nur noch dank eu
subventionen so gerade über die runden
kommen völlig bescheuert wir züchten
hochleistungskühe wirklich wie aus einem
horrorfilm
die genetik hat uns in den letzten
jahren sehr geholfen
die tiere werden immer produktiver
unterhalten stress besser aus wenn ich
sowas sehr schießt mir selber die milch
ein das ist ja auch wirklich krank wie
gesagt total krank und sowas hier nennt
man dann übrigens kein witz turbo
wir geben pro jahr vier mal so viel
milch wie kühe vor 80 jahren turbo co es
klingt fast wie so ein superheld wer
sorgt dafür dass über zucker kakao
unseren kindern die letzten szene
wegfrisst
oder dass eine milliarde chinesen legen
laktoseintoleranz ständig aufs klo
müssen es ist turbo coupe rächer der
enterbten radioaktiv verseuchtes
kraftfutter verleiht ihr über kulisse
kräfte 10.000 liter pro jahr
sie scheint sich zu mit ihrer nämlich
vergisst
jetzt im kino turbo coupe leute aus
stahl und genießen
eur q2 tag der abmeldung ein absoluter
sitzen film
[Musik]
sie sind der meinung das war meine damen
und herren
leider ist das leben dieser superhelden
aber alles andere als super um mal
wieder auf die traurige realität zu
kommen es ist ja ich sage es noch mal
unglaublich was wir denen antun
früher gab eine normale kuh bis zu 20
jahre lang milch die turbo ich schon
nach vier bis fünf jahren ein fall für
den schlachthof fast wie will man das
alles rechtfertigen
wir haben zahlen gesehen dass die im
schnitt 4,7 jahre alt werden ist es
nicht deutlich zu groß wenn die kuh in
den 47 jahren mehr milch produziert als
früher in zehn jahren
ist das auch okay ja außer für die kurie
vielleicht ist das ja die lösung für
unser deutsches rentenproblem kurz
hochleistung bringen und dann sterben
leider zeit die eu ihre
agrarsubventionen immer noch nach fläche
und eben nicht für nachhaltigkeit wofür
übrigens auch deutschland in brüssel
gesorgt hat so wofür die ganze quälerei
wofür für milch denn gerade kinder
brauchen milch erzählte uns seit
jahrzehnten in der schule brauchen die
zum beispiel milch nordrhein westfalen
hat diesen sommer als letztes bundesland
die zuschüsse für zuckerhaltige
schulmilch getränke gestrichen ist
schade schade denn nur weil in nrw so
viel kakao getrunken wurde schwärmt ja
ganz deutschland vom berühmten nrw
abitur ja ich fordere einen neuen
radikal ungeschminkten unterricht und
zwar schon ab der kita gnadenlose
frontalunterricht mit martin klempnow
heute die schwimme wahrheit über milch
kinder aufgepasst
[Musik]
jetzt habt ihr gelernt was
laktoseintoleranz ist
jahrelang hat man euch kleinen
gehirnwäsche opfern schwachsinn erzählt
hier sowas kauft hat irgendwas aber klar
da gibt es doch kinder schokolade für
die extraportion wenig der klasse
vollidiot seine kinder sind heute so
fett wie könnt ihr bei google maps aus
dem weltall sehen sicher mädchen hält
kalzium aber calcium ist auch in anderen
leckeren sachen drin statt euch diesen
weißen euter schleimerei zu ziehen könnt
ihr zum beispiel morgens auch mehr
gemüse essen gemüse bitte dann sagt man
weiter euren blöden sitzen säure wegen
laufen kühe dann so durch die gegend
eklig oder solche bilder seht ihr sonst
nur wenn opa sich am fkk-strand wirkt
ich will ja nur dass sie ein
realistisches bild von der
milchindustrie kriegt was die schweine
mit kühen machen ist ausbeutung pur und
dieser komische bär der steckt mit drin
mal sehen was die mädels heute an milch
geben was nur 50 liter wollt ihr mich
verarschen
wieso wirst du graf du [ __ ] bist du
blöd los komm her schwingt die hufe
schön kraftfutter bis dahin bleibt ja
bringt den ganzen soja scheiß aus
südamerika und jetzt gehts zum melken
sodass verkaufe ich jetzt den doofen
kleinen chinesen als modisch möglich als
nächstes der alte dosenmilch minute
jetzt guck doch nicht so traurig wir
finden schon ein anderes um gesundes
getränk für euch er hat alles lust mal
was zu probieren das heißt gin tonic
guten tag könnte ich sie für ein abo des
heute show youtube kanals begeistern
schließt gefälligst ein abo ab sofort